[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how it sounded yesterday as the
cleveland browns
qualified for the playoffs with a win
against the steelers 12
000 are going crazy inside first energy
stadium
and wherever you are this is starting to
become
very very real that the browns are going
to go to the playoff
they're in victory formation and baker
mayfield takes a knee
and the clock will wind down an amazing
story
the browns will get their 11th win of
the year they'll go to 11-5
and they're going to the playoffs
that's jim donovan the play-by-play
voice of the cleveland browns long
time sports fixture in cleveland and jim
kind enough to join us this morning
it's been a long time since you've been
able to have a call like that hasn't it
jimmy
yeah it really has dan long time 18 long
years
with a lot of twists and turns in there
what would have been like today if the
browns didn't make the playoffs
ah it would have been devastating it
really wouldn't have and i have to tell
you dan it had kind of a
that kind of a uneasy feeling because of
what happened going into the jets game
and you know the the bronze if they win
that game they're going to go to the
playoffs and then the coronavirus thing
hit and they lose all those wide
receivers and even in the stadium
yesterday
knowing that they went and they're in it
was very tight
all day long if they had if it had gone
the other way it would have been
devastating it really would have been
but it felt like that's 18 years of you
you know like that frustration sounded
like it was
you were speaking for browns fans but
you're speaking for yourself
as well i mean that it comes through
loud and clear how much did you feel
like you needed to
like scream or yell or unload something
well i have to tell you dan um it really
it really hit me
um and and the real
man finally got the first one and
there's no one you're just going to take
a knee and get out of there and they're
going to make the playoffs
it really hit me in a lot of different
ways because there are so many times
during
you know my tenure doing their games
that they just seemed
you know so lost in what they were doing
and there was there were so many reboots
and you never knew if the net if the
next one was going to be the right one
and i didn't know if this one was going
to be the right one
you know the way it came upon us last
year but it was uh
it was it was very emotional it really
was and i wish the place
had been packed i really do it would
have been a great great scene
as they say it would have been great
theater in there yesterday cleveland
sold on baker mayfield
yeah i think so i think in the last i
but i think it's
it's taken the second half of this
season i think just before the bye week
everybody was really still concerned
about it
interceptions his numbers on in that
category were up they were way up last
year but then
after they hit the bye week he really
took off and
whatever they did with him in the bye
week you know how they can make
some subtle changes with the offense and
he really got hot
and i think yesterday he kind of did it
a different way
he didn't do it with his arm a number of
times he did it with his legs he ran for
a couple of big first downs
to preserve the lead and build on the
lead so i think
cleveland is very comfortable with him
right now and they see him getting
better and better
inside this system what about obj's
future there
i think that um you know that's a that's
a big talking point here always because
uh with him here i mean there was a
there's certainly a presence with him
and um you know he did have uh he's had
isolated great games here
but they weren't great last year and and
he was disappointed with with what they
were doing
um i i think that i think for him
he wants to be a part of a winning team
i think he sees this thing
as a winning team i think that they're
very open and excited that it
to have him back because there is
something missing in their offense
without him
um you know that that ability to hit a
big home run ball
all the time um i think uh it would be a
good marriage if he comes back next year
i think that they're excited to see him
healthy once again and a part of the
team playing the steelers again
yeah advantage who
oh i would have to say advantage
steelers they're at home they'll have
all of their guys back
i mean big ben has he certainly has had
this the the bronze number since he came
into the nfl
and the fact that the browns and it
doesn't matter dan what the regime is or
who the coach is or who the players are
there is a real mental wall to get over
to try and win at heinz field
i mean they've only done it once since
they've opened up heinz field so
that's a big big factor and they've lost
games in a lot of different ways in
there they've been in them
they've lost them in heartbreaking
fashion they're one trip to the playoffs
it was a heartbreaking loss
at heinz field so that's a big hurdle
for them that's that's a big step for
them
do you remember the lowest of lows in
calling a browns game
yeah i think when they were those two
years the one in 15
but the 0 and 16 and the last game in
that 0 and 16 season was at heinz field
and it looked and the steelers weren't
playing anybody because they had already
had their playoff
position all decided and the bronzer
going down the field to kind of win the
game
and uh you know they drop a pass on
fourth down
that was a simple throw they would have
gotten them the first down and it would
have been first and goal
and i just said oh my god i mean that is
that that just says it all
and then a week later dan and you guys
probably remember this
i mean they had a parade in cleveland
for the 0 and 16
season and it was like 25 below wind
chill down at the stadium and there were
10 000 people there
that was a low point i felt well
congrats
you're you're an announcer a
play-by-play voice for a playoff
team feels great yeah
no vacation for you in january jim
that's okay
not much not much going on anyway around
here uh hey great to talk to you thanks
and uh
have fun this weekend we will thanks a
lot dan happy new year that's uh jim
donovan
he's the play-by-play voice of the
cleveland browns